PER VETERAN HEAD COACH
DISAPPOINTING ONE MOS
HERE COMES THE CAPTAIN
IT
AND I ONCE DRAFTED BY THE BLUES
BUT NEVER PLAYED HERE FROM THE E
ANGELO AGAIN.
BOBBLED THEREBY BOY
PAD THE ON
MAN IN AS HE PLAYS IT LOOSE TO
O'REILLY. BACK TO THOSE POINTS
THIS UP.
THE BOY A GOOD EXAMPLE GOAL, 20
THE BACK END LOOKINGEAR.
>> LASTER WAS A KICK IN THE
PANTS TO LOSE TO MONTREA AT
IT FROM THE LEFT TO THE RIGHT IN
BLUESE TERRIFIC THE TO
>> IT'S A PLACE TO BE FOR AND ON
HI
SO THE LINE WHITE
GIVE THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS CREDIT E
HERE IN THE THIRD AND LEAD THE
>> 1-2 TONIGHT.
HERE HE IS IN FRONT, RYAN
O'REILLY WON THE FACE-OFF TO
START OFF IN.
CENTERED, OFF THE BACK OF HAND T
AND ESCAPES GOING TOEFENSE, TWOY
O'REILLY.
>> AS